tanto la carga formal como el estado de
oxidación son formas de contar
electrones y las dos son muy útiles
vamos a empezar con la carga formal la
carga formal es la carga hipotética que
obtendríamos suponiendo que todos los
electrones de los enlaces se comparten
equitativamente ok y esto sucede cuando
en un enlace los electrones se dividen
en dos cada átomo se queda con uno de
los electrones vayamos a la estructura
de puntos de la izquierda son
exactamente la misma es una molécula de
metanol lo que queremos hacer es
asignarle una carga formal a este
carbono y entonces nos tenemos que fijar
en los electrones de los enlaces aunque
hay siempre que tenemos un enlace
sabemos que está compuesto por dos
electrones y eso pasa con todos los
enlaces que hay aquí tenemos que poner
todos estos electrones y para asignarle
una carga formal al carbono tenemos que
pensar en el número de electrones
valencia- en un átomo libre de carbono y
este es el número de electrones de
valencia que se supone que debe de tener
cualquier átomo de carbono y bueno todos
sabemos que el carbono se supone que
tiene 4 electrones de valencia y a este
número le vamos a restar el número de
electrones de valencia en el átomo ya
enlazado o sea el número de electrones
que tiene el carbono a su alrededor en
nuestra estructura de puntos ahora como
estamos calculando la carga formal de
este carbono porque la carga formal
estamos pensando que todos los
electrones de los enlaces se están
compartiendo equitativamente aunque ya
estamos pensando en un enlace covalente
tenemos aquí un enlace entre dos átomos
si estos dos átomos están compartiendo
los electrones de este enlace
equitativamente lo que podemos hacer es
dividirlo a la mitad y que cada átomo se
quede con un electrón y entonces nos
seguimos por acá y llegamos a este
entre el hidrógeno y el carbono y pues
también tenemos dos electrones en un
enlace podemos repartir los a la mitad y
que el hidrógeno se quede con un
electrón y el carbono se quede con el
otro y bueno lo mismo por acá y lo mismo
por acá entonces ahora cuántos
electrones de valencia vemos alrededor
del carbono en este dibujo vamos a
resaltar los tenemos por aquí 1 2
4 entonces ese es el número de
electrones de valencia en el átomo
enlazado entonces tenemos que poner por
aquí un 4 y 4 menos 4 es igual a cero
así es que la carga formal de este
carbono es cero vamos a escribirlo por
aquí en esta molécula la carga formal
del carbono es igual a cero ahora vamos
con el estado de oxidación que también
llamado el número de oxidación y una
definición para el estado de oxidación
es la carga hipotética que obtenemos
suponiendo que todos los electrones del
enlace son asignados al átomo más
electrón negativo del enlace entonces
vamos a usar esta estructura de puntos
de la derecha y vamos a asignarle un
estado de oxidación a este carbono creo
que ahí tenemos que fijarnos en los
electrones del enlace
por lo que en este diagrama vamos a
poner aquí todos los electrones de los
enlaces que cada enlace tiene dos
electrones
y ahora sí ya podemos calcular el estado
de oxidación de este carbono
empezamos por aquí con el número de
electrones de valencia en el carbono
libre y ya sabemos que el carbono se
supone que tiene 4 electrones de
valencia y a eso le tenemos que restar
el número de electrones de valencia en
el átomo enlazado o sea el número de
electrones que realmente tiene el
carbono en este dibujo pero esta vez
vamos a pensar en un enlace iónico
porque todos los electrones del enlace
son asignados al átomo más electro
negativo por keith vamos a pretender que
los enlaces covalentes en realidad son
enlaces iónicos porque pues todos los
electrones del enlace están siendo
asignados al átomo que es más electro
negativo ok se están asignando todos los
electrones a un mismo átomo los átomos
ya no van a compartir los electrones del
enlace el que sea más
negativo se va a quedar con todos
entonces pues vamos a empezar pensando
en qué tan electro negativo es el
carbono comparado con el oxígeno y bueno
sabemos que el oxígeno es más electrón
negativo que el carbono
entonces el oxígeno se va a quedar con
todos los electrones de este enlace
aunque hay entonces el oxígeno se queda
con todos los electrones y ahora tenemos
que pensar en qué tan el electrón
negativo es el carbono con respecto al
hidrógeno pues sabemos que el carbono es
un poco más electro negativo que el
hidrógeno entonces el carbono se va a
quedar con todos los electrones de este
enlace y pues lo mismo sucede con estos
dos enlaces aunque hay el carbono es más
electro negativo que el hidrógeno y
entonces se queda con todos los
electrones del enlace y por acá igual el
carbono es más electro negativo que el
hidrógeno por lo que se queda con todos
los electrones del enlace entonces
cuántos electrones hay alrededor del
carbono pues tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 como
craig tenemos 6 electrones alrededor del
carbono y 4 - 6 es igual a menos 2 el
carbono tiene un estado de oxidación
igual a menos 2 y recuerda cuando
estamos hablando de estados de oxidación
los átomos ya no comparten ni un solo
electrón ok el átomo más electro
negativo es el que se queda con todos
los electrones del enlace y bueno tanto
la carga formal como el estado de
oxidación son dos formas de contar
electrones dos formas bastante extremas
y ninguna de las dos son perfectas en
una estamos suponiendo que se reparten
los electrones de cada enlace de forma
equitativa 1 y 1 y en la otra estamos
suponiendo que alguno de los dos átomos
se queda con todos los electrones aunque
ninguno de los dos conceptos es perfecto
el mundo real pero funcionan bastante
bien cuando estamos haciendo nuestras
estructuras de puntos y pensando en
reacciones químicas